[Musique]
du braquet l'industrie michael sait
jamais mais on dira j'ai commencé en
bottes blanches comment obtenir
[Musique]
je suis fait qu'on s'était dit hugh
johson gb s exporter
[Musique]
passer une bonne soirée bienvenue on est
sur skyrock pour cette émission spéciale
on va découvrir cet album qui sort dans
une quinzaine de jours il s'agit de
tanaka et notre artiste vous connaissez
c'est l'un des poids lourds du rap
français bienvenue à toi ma star onze
ans après en pleine forme pas fort mon
bien détendu en équipe toujours un
ennemi mais on est là on est en famille
et nous avons monsieur dj lord issa ici
même on va faire le tour justement de la
famille dans 1 900 juste avant je
voulais rappeler aussi que ma star ses
douze albums 5 mixtape des centaines de
millions de vues sur le net
tu peux y aller parce qu'on va écouter
un morceau en exclu c'est un extrait de
son album on le découvre tout de suite
sur skyrock
je peux trouver du grisou soi n'est pas
une personne tupi né à calais demain
matin et toc militaire garde à vue
demain la fin
avait bien souhaité vivre air bien joué
en attendant moi c'est un vrai sapin
préposé
le projet est le chemin est tombée tel
un pôle emploi
alors tu viens pas non je suis bien
l'enjeu
tu as peur de monter qua non je
le redoutais
monte à l'heure
voir
pour moi
ce soir mon heure
savatan c'est rare de voir ces
problèmes qu'est ce qu'il ya je parle de
venir voir ce que je passe bien
j'ai du temps libre à sa
manière il a dit prêt vendredi du mois
ça veut dire les salaires et sont tombés
donc tu perds pas de temps entre les
clients d'accor asie
o le cafard en bas lac léman est ce ton
cousin ça je veux que tu fasses les
tourner avec lui tu as compris ça change
quoi à deux vous êtes grillés tu fais
des tournées tout seul je veux plus te
voir avec je vais posera la guerre tout
dépend ce que tu veux je m'en bats les
couilles et je veux plus voir et trouver
- tap11 qui nettoie ce bordel dans c'est
quoi ça en un jour
maintenant je trouve la porte et
pourtant je trouve plutôt
sergio défense toshimi kitazawa mais je
ne dépense pas ajouter de qui tenir
d'accord je coupe de france maintient
qu'il n'a plus tueur vient boire
chaque les reds up les trois fois tu
commences par lui c'est jusqu'à l'anc
fossé ska rock
vas-y fille bon ma star sous les
conduisant mot sur celui là je vois
derrière la vitre ton acolytes depuis
tant d'années celui qu'on surnomme le
magicien et qui bosse encore avec toi
sur cet album un sûreté n'est qu'à 6
snow et je tenais particulièrement lui
faire un gros gros gros big up parce que
on va fêter nos 10 ans de collaboration
sont donc qu'ils ont ils étaient là
depuis les pro métiers trop maetur
premier album je lui dois tout est chez
nous on est des fidèles donc à la vie à
la mort et
ça c'est une aussi prompts à cody qui a
la santé et j'espère que si tu m'entends
frérot tient bon ah bon mais qu'est ce
qu'il est et ce qu'il a encore fait
qu'audi bas
tu sais faire du véhicule avec la
bagarre avec la crim mais j'aimerais que
vous avez pris du sursis moi je prédis
sur 6 et lui malheureusement et là près
du ferme bon ben on le salue alors
grosse force informé et je rappelle que
pour agir l'émission n'hésitez pas avec
ma star notre invité
alors vocalement le plus encore non ce
cas mais non c'est pas les trappes de
munster en plus ce soir ah ouais je suis
branché ça fait deux ans que je le
revois tes maquette c'est à jamais
calculé il et on essaye de rentrer dans
le studio pour lui parler non
se recoupent
ça va leur a bien
ouais d'accord mais c'est un hoax ou
chimie bon eh les gars il ya trop de
monde à aller tout ce qui bouge le
passage en bouche allez on dégage jamais
bord du haut de ses toiles on t'a dit
quoi parle bien aussi toi
qu'est-ce qui te mettait ses loges
dégagement ton petit peu le fil usb sera
le passage désolé mais je gère
ça sera tout bois naîtra peugeot sa
frêle tiens ma gueule avec ton gars wise
as classe chinois li date et romy droit
on sera mal tu magie toutes les meufs
qu'on pourra céder frère il sera plus
donner de la tête tant flamme pas là au
moment c'est juste un tipi craver cabaye
- toi t'es quoi des avants
moi c'est simple moi c'est un programme
dur c'est un papa plein temps pré
rentrée tu devais te sens pas à leur
sport
[Musique]
tard
deux inédits exclu bref le morceau
s'appelle castro produit par m'amène dj
snow le journal didier ce n'est toujours
là ça s'appelle castro ce sera dans un
instant et puis dans un instant s'il ne
bougeait pas il ya des questions des
auditeurs vous pouvez intervenir en
direct on peut poser toutes les
questions toutes les caches tu connais
je sais
forme et étant posé cette question moi
aussi ma star avec nous et la suite de
ce premier tracé après ça
presstore
pour le tenir
jugement le glas de charges eau
le conte - tu nous fasses monter dans le
studio mais non c'est chaud les gauchos
et aggravent du monde ce soir ça au
bordel c'est pas possible si je te fais
maintient près
non
fabriquer les français
et son époque non je ne connais pas
comment ça tu me connais pas fils de
[ __ ] qu'à la longue on lâchera
intégreront la haye gros bien sûr qu'il
me connaît je t'avais cuire 2 minutes
oneswarm mais c'est bien on y va
bonne soirée bones pratiquions voilà tu
fais quoi ravir nouveau
tracé coûte du temps et c'est un lot de
fils de [ __ ] également son humour je
vais l'appeler tout de suite
vas-y
apple le temps après tu me le placement
ouais c'est appeler vion fait vite 6
jours nous entends plus te voir qu'il
fait des réductions à des clients
pour le rendez vous
la vrai rebondissement n'a pas ébranlé
fois choqué ce forum tout mer les ordres
faut prendre tous fidel castro je dois
prendre tout meilleurs les hommes faut
prendre tout
choqué tous meilleurs les autres faut
prendre
faut prendre tout pas comme soldats
postés chaque jour je suis remonté à
battre pour le rendez vous wa ma star
aux
lèvres amandiers masa maz'air à défaut
[Applaudissements]
on
va tous les questions des auditeurs
installe toi et c'est parti avec un
premier coup de fil qui ne viennent
à l'ao fred je suis à l'antenne en
direct comment tu t'appelles je
m'appelle clément avec le mans
et je voulais dire je te kiffe depuis je
suis gamin
heures moto alors c'est quoi ta question
clément
un million de questions me viennent en
tête ma carte et le boss du rap game
j'entends sa voix dans le pen je connais
ton parcours parker du fric dans la
fripe open mais c'est aime pas les
suceurs donc je vais pas faire dans la
dentelle la route est droite dure car
j'ai acheté tout est album tu fous les
roannais couple comme si je mélangeais
les alcools [ __ ] ce soir j'ai pas de
bol je suis resté sur le peuple porte
donc je t'ai écrit un texte ma plume
bébé belge et la patte folle j'ai trop
de questions je me demande pourquoi
victimes eurent tout et failli te
fatigue pas je vais répondre pour toi tu
as fait ce que personne n'a fait faut
dire que tu perds tes couilles toi j'te
kiffe l'été un fils de respect dû rester
courtois pourquoi tu ne penses qu'à ta
gueule mme ashton n'ont pas de bois tél
j'écoute en boucle totti tueur à gages
mais tu n'as pas de galles [ __ ]
d'époque dont traverse j'ai les bras du
cône également carte de travers tous des
trams mais khune principe on osait mais
pas l'un vers ce petit navire est
fatigué trois petites fées trop vieux je
suis là bas ça qui sait
pourquoi tu as trahi ton et qu'il gros
ta mémoire est sélective sorte de
longueur de technique ça fait toujours
été au top c'est facile parce que tu as
persia les bonnes des magnétoscopes mais
parlons totalement grippé avec des stars
de la pop dans la vie de ma mère j'ai
jamais autant rigolé d'un flop les
portes à cause du latrines todo mais il
a osé te dire que tu as vous sentez la
ces données
votre honneur au club n'est pas le tome
i bien peu la meinau faut pour toi tu
n'as plus d'autonomie à poche
en direct
dans l'émission dans ce planète rap
consacrer à ma star on avait clément en
direct par téléphone je tiens à dire
évidemment que c'était pas prévu en tout
cas ce qu'il allait nous sortir
l'instant à l'antenne en train de réagir
pas mal aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est ma station skyrock tandis qu au
hamas tant sa voix les bons les bons il
est bon bah si tu voulu répondre
n'hésite pas si tu me répondras clément
connaît c'est le rap game c'est ça que
j'aime dans deux émissions justement
trade 3 les gens y viennent epsilon la
gouache et membres d'équipage mais tu
sais très bien est né dans son salon
leur était devant moi le rugby
[Rires]
toujours avec nous en direct à l'antenne
que quelque chose a ajouté à ma star moi
je suis pas vraiment salon les gars je
suis en bas
alors lâchez vous dire on égrène sur un
planète rap d'anthologie franchement
pour ce planète rap consacrer à ma star
c'est énorme ce qui se passe c'est que
les mois qui ont pas à priori aux portes
de leur accueil
qu'est ce qu'on décide qu est ce que tu
décides
mon second du monde
eh ben c'est parti à l'est
ces kits mémoire
est l'album qui s'appelle tanaka et je
vois qu'on est en train d'ouvrir la
porte il me semble que oui c'est nous
c'est clément
[Applaudissements]
a laissé passer clemmons laissez-passer
dégâts s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
on va essayer de bien l'accueillir mais
ayez le courage de monter un stato à
clément aussi quand le casque on le
casse on va tous mourir ton micro voilà
bienvenue dans ce plat des trappes
consacrer à ma star qu'est ce tu fous
tombe à d'ailleurs appelé mans bah en
fait je faisais une livraison
et que je me suis dit que ce serait le
moyen de rencontrer l'instar des fans de
la star en fait c'est ça ouais moi ma
star scène le rappeur préféré avec booba
rohff la mafia k 1 fry bon je suis
désolé c'est que vous êtes en clash mais
je kiffe bien lacrymo si tu vois mon
père quand j'étais petit il me faisait
écouter ntm et ge qui fait un mort et
donc maintenant que tu as en face de ma
star qu'est ce que tu as envie de lui
dire
en fait une star je vais envoyer vous la
maison mais il m'a jamais répondu
c'était l'occasion de lui montrer un
petit peu ce que tu vaux maintenant non
qu'est ce que tu en penses ma star est
ce que c'était il serait d'accord dit
qu'il était chaud il est monté tes joues
en balance une instru bon on peut
essayer ok on va laisser partir
maintenant
[Musique]
oh
appelle-moi page charles mon équipe et
j'ai leur égard tout risque de p3 dans
l'auditoire qui est là là c'est son père
a marqué les douze fiches quand tous mes
potes s'amuse la rue a tué mon en force
de taper le poil salima manga son fils
passe mais c'est pas le même maillot je
suis dans le match dans la grande motte
la tête du réseau avec mes rayons x au
tout à l'égout quelques bandes ici de
pote je te fais un quart de tableau
n'est pas et ça fait pipi ou tipi suis
dans mon collège de tête sur une plage
comme tipi direct et affichage en aide
nous attend sur le gange la présente en
ménageant le moteur milieu du texan
parce que j'ai des pilotes à glaçons via
du lkp sont jetés dans la boîte la
démo de rillieux du diable sans titre ce
qui suit leur hangar sent pas bien
réelle car sauf que pendant la pâque
accent
des pays ont toujours les décrets la rue
la fête nationale les trop peu ma mère
et ma soeur mon fils mais des fois qu'un
prison pomme
j'ai compté tellement c'est ont toujours
mais d'être là
les crains pour ma mère et ma soeur
une fois que la prison pour mineurs
[Musique]
marseille
c'est quoi cette bière dit que tu viens
de faire le tattoo unique et appuyer le
game la taille mais promu comblé parce
que c'était pas prévu c'était août avoir
fait cela s est passé trop vite frères
vérité j'ai même pas réfléchi immostar
il a réagi comme engrais unités vénère
où il a du coup je sais pas je veux pas
le regarder et bien au gardasil elle va
sortir c'est l'occasion de parler
les frères mineurs qui m'a pas il faut
que j'allais livrer
à droite je pense pour un but de sow
tony
jetant même pas regardé fred choqué
pressé ne sera pas qu'on le pensait
peut-être besoin tout ce que tu appelles
la vidéo se sent encore le buzz à part
ça passe ça ouais ouais ce moment il ya
un master qui fait napster pour lancer
un album ça chauffe je peux vous emmener
il faut y aller mais à l'eau
commence a du retard une folle équipe
demain à midi hier ses taux qui prend
tous les risques en travaux pour ce mec
là et tu prends même pas d'argent
ça serait moi j'aurais répondu fontang
plantes et mounir les gants et la raison
venir et va me rendre fou tous les deux
si on n'y va pas fall est vrai qu eva tu
te débrouilles
quoi
annoncé mort maintenant j'ai envie de
venir avec vous c'est pour la bonne
cause quelle bonne cause je t'explique
saâne par les quinze ans je sais pas
conduire un scooter je peux pas livré
donc c'est mort ok alors
allez
arrêtez avec vos sourires s'affichaient
pas conduire j'ai dit
j'ai une grosse merde voilà
qui se retrouvent dans la merde tout le
temps ce qui bat ces mots
on verra bien c'est qui qui va le
dernier
évidemment surtout la déroute nous
souhaitons aussi
il en train d'exploser les vues il ya
tous les leaders ce qui se régale j'ai
demandé à inès de le faire venir la
soirée tu as fais
moi confiance là il faut qu'on fasse
croire aux gens que ça ne touche pas
d'accord donc ce soir tu la trappe tu
fais tu fais une story tu fais un staff
avec lui que comme ça qu'on va dormir le
faire trouvant away la coupe monde non
s'il vient me parler junique sa mère ok
je
[Musique]
heureusement pas les couilles bon palet
que je bouge pas d'ici là
bah
comment
partout les
gadgi quitte à me faire mais ça vaut
quoi ça dégage
pas pourquoi tu t'appelais être apte à
leur talent ouais c'est lui moi c'est
moi et sur les raisons parce que toi
bien je pars son recours
en 3 h 15
je voudrais vidage
il ya un souci ouais et à main event de
planter là bas alors ouais c'est pas
grave tu enchaînes tu continues
je suis là je suis tout seul je
comprends rien du tout élève
à rigaud c'est la rdc les pilules bleues
ouais t'as compris et entendus fabien tu
sais qui c'est la weed il faut bien deux
c'est le client brahim francis c'est la
weed est sûr que ça va aller non parce
que je te préviens si tu fais de la
merde mounir va nous tuer les gens
vraiment jusqu'à ce que murray l'a
compris fais moi confiance était fous
toi moi confiance et vous comment et
mavuba
[Musique]
est une voie non est de m'obliger julien
atp mpg faire des accents tout ça
surtout tu dis chez par la chambre et
d'avancer
[Musique]
marie do carmo ni fabien nadja a bien
sûr la cliente
la crème qu'ils valident le petit
donc maintenant le problème
si on me suggère une idée
je te parle des preuves
[Musique]
allez
on sent ici aussi 600 dans la
ça fait 2 120 de chaque roue oui je
boude non plus j'ai déjà payé comment
stopper les vendanges bonne soirée marc
gaubert souvenir c'est bonne soirée
rentrée berra vote sans risque
discrétion tout rempli qui s'intitule
the time in texto de tueur je n'en veux
pas du tout pas du tout et tous mes
potes qui sont barrées je te plains
grammes seulement comment sens-tu
prochain grimpant sur mon prochain
a dit quoi
je ne sais pas
on se passe un truc un peu nous débutons
triste elle n'a pas d'augmenter tout à
l'heure
il sera toujours comme ça tu avais 44
demande une photo
karim car son grand-père excuses mais on
préfère une petite auto avec plaisir par
ces épreuves techniques mais aussi une
tuerie la saison sur une légende femme
nancy l'épaule
cool bonne soirée les renverser
et on coupe les dents pour ce il est
incroyable incroyable talent un bon
leurs frais c'est un bon
[Musique]
elle a noté notre technique à non [ __ ]
que wake la mesure s'applique à bord ce
qui est pour quelque chose wazir prendre
comme ça
à la fin
mickey soir bravo petit geste nos frères
[ __ ] ce qui faisait son aile pour moi
tu es le meilleur c'est cool c'est
gentil un bon sujet mais attention ces
métaux compte les choses que ça fait son
hautbois en vérité moi je voulais juste
marquer le coup mais moi aussi je suis
fan de la star depuis que je suis tout
petit d'ailleurs est ce que tu penses tu
peux me rendre un service
ces vieux ça
concert demain soir à l'elysée
montmartre
le cerveau je vais garder comme porte
bonheur c'était mon premier concert et
j'avais dix piges et du coup c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai su que je voulais
faire du rap tu vois je pense qu'il ya
moyen que ma star est une signe la place
vas-y bouge pas on gagne merci beaucoup
à peine mis hors combat
ça fait tilt
n'empêche qu'il a encore
koné stewart reste présent tapage rail
se présentera pas à
jeun
merci c'est normal un vrai fan et je
voulais dire je suis désolé pour les
petites pièces dans le freestyle tout à
l'heure mais c'était juste ma manière à
moi de montrer que je te su depuis le
début du mois tokyo tse on va dépeindre
le temps en temps je kiffe envoie du
coup avec moi cela on a une idée pour
vous les proposer d'enregistrer un feat
c'est ça chauffe
attendez vous êtes sérieux les gars
mais quand vous voulez quand vous voulez
manchots
[Musique]
on s'embrasse amant bordj amenant même
pattakos triplement des moyens de la
viande et du cheylard savez vous comment
je vais manger des frites
mais non
mais non dit chinoise bhp parisien i et
j des soucis à manger que sa ou ses
couches de dire
j'aimerais
atx mais bien là
hu
voire inquiète alors regardons fait une
première prise tranquille tu te mets pas
la pression comme si tu étais à la
maison ok ok
je connais déjà un truc
vas-y mais mon bon samatar en bout donc
ça vient des tripes t'inquiète
dérapage aucune envie ouais bah la même
pour tous vas-y hockey
[Musique]
j'arrive dans kent comme un braqueur
devant west c'est là restez pas des
beaux-arts je pars capuche et comme un
bosseur j'ai déjà les hits de l'été dans
mon beau serge est la cocu et les condés
sous ma semelle le seul truc qui peuvent
se passer le sommeil je rappe tellement
harcelée on dirait que je suis tombé
dedans quand j'étais petit peu mais
quand ils docteur c'était des prod aval
abel tablait sur un phénomène dans le
monde des gens prennent au même genou
manquant de guerriers de moneuse ayant
dû comme jour férié je rentre au cabinet
j'appelle à bruncher un bug dans la
matrice
jetez un coup t'arracher c'est tellement
plonge mais le feu sans la patrie apache
[Musique]
clémence et karim avec nous vas-y
j'arrive
il est très très chaude
bravo max et bien
[Applaudissements]
commencé trop lent vont poser dans un
studio comme ça franchement ça fait trop
plaisir eh ben dis toi que c'est ici
chez toi maintenant merci beaucoup moins
stars attendues qua non pour vos débuts
en gros je sors mon album dans deux
semaines si je veux le manche ont pu
causer dedans
tu es sérieux quelqu'un qui a commandé
de la bouffe la
annonce à ses bras et mon cousin et je
dois le ramener chez nous après
donc tu descendre au sous-sol
à temps mais c'est qui le mec avec lui
arriver comme ça ça je crois que c'est
mounir
mounir repreneur il s'agit d'un parvis
ouais je travaille pour le [ __ ] mais
pourquoi tu ramènes des barjots comme ça
chez moi à toi
et moi on laisse manger
salut les amis j'espère que tout se
passe bien révolu regarde ici t'es chez
moi donc tu fais pas dit ferme ta gueule
quoi faire je vais tuer fils de [ __ ] un
bagel jeu juste venu voir mon artiste
pour le féliciter parti doucement
doucement
parce que tu l'auras pas dit
c'est moi qui payais sa première mixtape
à lui vous voulez quoi et on peut jeter
des grains de rouge et montrons frérot
[Musique]